well here we go again activision
blizzard is once again under fire for
allegedly encouraging a toxic workplace
culture where women were mistreated and
discriminated against but this time
there's a pretty important new detail
because allegedly all the terrible
things we've heard about activision
wizard over the past year go all the way
to the top
all right so in case you missed our
previous three videos about the subject
activision blizzard is currently being
sued by the state of california's
department of fair employment and
housing for allegedly enabling and
encouraging a toxic workplace culture
that was brutal towards women last we
heard about all this blizzard had
installed new co-leads and activision
blizzard ceo bobby kodek called his
company's response to the lawsuit tone
deaf but guess what turns out kodak
allegedly wrote that tone-deaf response
himself on tuesday kristin grind ben
fritz and sarah e needleman of the wall
street journal published an article
detailing codic's part in the whole
activision blizzard saga before we get
into the allegations laid out in the
video i just wanted to let you know that
we are going to be discussing sexual
violence as we go on i just wanted to
let you know before we go further the
article starts out with an allegation
that in 2018 a former sledgehammer games
employee sued the company because she
said she was raped twice by a supervisor
who had pressured her to drink too much
at work events and in the office that
supervisor later identified in the
article as javier panamano was also
accused in the lawsuit by the lawyers of
having sexually harassed another woman
at the studio kodak allegedly received
an email about this and did not take any
action himself which directly
contradicts his alleged statements to
his own board of directors that he
wasn't aware of these kinds of issues at
the company and that the ones he did
know about were mostly happening on the
blizzard side of the company and had
already been resolved according to the
article activision which owned
sledgehammer games settled the lawsuit
out of court and kodak allegedly didn't
tell his board of directors about the
lawsuit the accusations of rape or the
settlement other allegations related to
codec in the article include that he
covered up and protected dan bunting the
co-head of treyarch another
activision-owned studio that works on
call of duty when bunting was accused of
sexually harassing a female employee in
2017. the article alleges that codec had
heard about senior employees at
activision blizzard harassing assaulting
or otherwise mistreating women multiple
times over the years and allegedly he
wasn't just hearing about it he was
occasionally part of it too the wall
street journal alleges that kodak was
accused of telling one of his assistants
he was going to destroy her in 2006 and
that in 2007 he was sued by a former
flight attendant on the private jet he
co-owned because he allegedly fired her
and told her he was going to destroy her
when she said that the pilot had
sexually harassed her but the most truly
confusing part of this whole thing is
that tone death thing i mentioned
earlier see back in october an email
sent to all activision blizzard
employees was leaked to the press the
email was sent by fran townsend who is
the company's chief compliance officer
and was roundly criticized for calling
the lawsuit meritless even code
criticized it calling it tone death but
in a truly insane twist turns out he
might have written it himself according
to the wall street journal kodak drafted
that email and asked it to be sent out
by townsend who later stepped down from
her role as the head of the activision
blizzard women's network as a result of
the fallout in the wake of the news
breaking the abk workers alliance an
informal coalition of activision
blizzard employees spoke out on twitter
calling for codex resignation after the
news broke earlier this year about the
alleged toxic workplace culture at the
blizzard side of the company many
high-profile members of the blizzard
team stepped down including president j
allen brack at the time the abk workers
alliance didn't call for resignations
like that so their call for codex
resignation is pretty significant the
abk workers alliance organized a walkout
on tuesday as well which saw over a
hundred employees leave their work from
home setups to stand outside the office
and call for codex resignation the
walkout and the general response from
employees received a lot of positive
coverage from the press and the hashtag
firebobbycodec even trended on twitter
on tuesday and bloomberg's jason
schreier reports that the ceo of sony's
playstation division jim ryan wrote an
email to employees criticizing kodak
after the news broke amidst everything
about kodak the original wall street
journal report also noted that jen
o'neil one of the co-heads appointed to
lead blizzard after brac stepped down
told activision blizzard that she didn't
believe the company could fix their
culture problem o'neill who stepped down
earlier this month less than two months
after taking the position as coley to
blizzard allegedly sent an email to
activision's legal team in which she
said that she had been sexually harassed
while working at the company and that
she was being paid less than her male
colleague despite being appointed at the
same time on wednesday ign's cat bailey
reported that o'neill was only offered a
contract with equal pay after tendering
her resignation to be clear what
allegedly happened here is that after
bombshell reports that activision
blizzard was enabling the mistreatment
and harassment of women and that women
employees were underpaid at the company
they promoted a woman to a position of
leadership and then
underpaid her
genius move amidst all this news
activision blizzard stalk took a massive
dive on tuesday and there are reports
that some shareholders are calling for
codex resignation mind you according to
schreier again this group of
shareholders isn't exactly the most
powerful by themselves ultimately while
there are an immense number of voices
calling for codex resignation
there are some more powerful voices that
are still standing behind him on tuesday
activision blizzard's board of directors
put out a statement defending kodak
saying that he's appropriately addressed
workplace issues brought to his
attention which is something some people
have questioned the journal says the
kodak did not or lied by a mission if
you want to do not mention the board the
board comes out immediately and endorses
him which is right i mean if there was a
full vetting by the board and there was
a big investigation i get that but if
the board didn't know david then
who are they to say everything's fine
and then late on tuesday game developers
brian francis reported on an activision
blizzard all hands meeting where
executives answered pre-screened
questions from employees according to
game developer the company reportedly
told employees in that meeting that
activision blizzard's zero tolerance
policy which only launched in october by
the way won't apply to kodak because
what he was directly accused of doing
happened a decade ago and they don't
have evidence notably back in 2008
arbitration decided that kodak had to
pay out 200 thousand dollars to that
flight attendant we mentioned earlier
and that mostly brings us up to today
it's definitely possible that kodak
could resign but with the board standing
behind him and only a small number of
shareholders calling for his head
just seems kind of unlikely to me see
sometimes to the kinds of people who
make these decisions in these kinds of
situations
money matters more than morals codec has
made a lot of money for activision
shareholders over the years and they're
interested in staying in a position to
keep making that kind of money and look
a lot of you are probably out there
wondering right now if you should still
be playing and buying activision games
after all this and i don't really want
to tell you what you should or shouldn't
be doing sure some bad company might
make less money if you don't buy their
game but also some decent person working
on that game might get fired when it
isn't a hit it's kind of a shitty
situation no matter what you do and
ultimately it's the executives at the
top who have an easy time lining up new
gigs when they leave their jobs while in
the games industry it's often really
hard to find new work when you don't
have hits in your portfolio look what
i'm saying is you're not making some
kind of grand moral decision by enjoying
a video game ultimately it's your choice
whether you want to play activision
blizzard games or not and it doesn't
make you a terrible person for falling
on either side of it because it's not
your job to fix activision blizzard's
problems it's activision blizzard's job
at the end of the day i'm sure we'd all
like it if activision blizzard fixed
their [ __ ] because real people's lives
are being hurt here
i'm just not very confident in what kind
of change is gonna happen with guys like
kodak at the helm but who knows maybe if
the chorus of voices calling for change
gets loud enough
actual change can happen
you